it being 1:00 I'm going to go ahead and
open our work session on
s499 FN
uh I think we set this up teed this up
so that Mr Ripple would start this
session by making sure we understood the
fiscal note because the fiscal note had
changed and it was more complex than
what I could
process sure uh and we did Issue a new
fiscal note last week so just to make
sure everybody has the most current
version in front of them it should say
amended
418 does everybody have that
one yes okay I have it um um so I guess
I'll preface this by saying I'm far from
an expert in education policy so there
are some people here from doe to speak
to this bill so as far as the details of
the programs themselves because there
are a number of
programs created by this bill or
affected by this bill um and they would
be in a better position than I am to
describe them in detail but I can at
least walk you through the fiscal note
and point you to the sections of the
build with the fiscal
impact the estimated amount of that
impact uh and whether the bill contains
an appropriation and what the source of
that appropriation is so I'll first call
your attention to the
table that's in the fiscal
notes uh that shows FY 25 26 27 and a
out I I I see the table I I'm not seeing
words at each each subt to indicate
which part of the bill it's speaking to
so I can go through that as I go through
the fiscal note okay um we'll start off
with the positions so doe has estimated
that if all of the programs contained in
this bill are implemented uh they'll
need three new positions at a total cost
of 351,000 in the first year 345 in the
second and 357 in the thir but I say so
I have to stop you again okay I because
I I'm I want to track so you said we're
going to start with the tables you're on
the table on the second page right of
the fiscal note that's correct okay so
fy2 Physicians 351,000 that's correct
all right gotcha but I say that those
will be needed if everything is
implemented because there's a chance
that not everything will be implemented
the reason this fiscal note was updated
last week is because the most recent
Senate Amendment contained contingency
language uh saying that if the
appropriation for the various for three
of the provisions are insufficient uh
the department can delay implementation
of those programs um so that brings us
to the next component breakfast after
with section two of the bill on page one
starting on 19 addresses the breakfast
after the Bell program and the
statistics that need to be kept in order
to uh determine whether School District
should participate in that program okay
so you said section two line 19 I think
yes uh on page two or page one page one
believe and really the new language is
only on the bottom of page
one okay I'm just I'm just going really
slowly
sure and this is one of those instances
in which the contingency language added
by the Senate would apply so you'll
notice in the table under contains
appropriation it says there there's an
appropriation of $1 in general funds and
an open warrant for federal
funds
um so this table reflects the state
share of costs there's a related Federal
share but most of these appropriations
of federal funds assume the federal
funds will be able to cover the state
share in the event that that isn't
possible and it may not be uh the
department would be able to suspend
implementation of the
programs and I say it may not be
possible because generally speaking uh
federal funds can't be used to match
other federal
funds so this is one of three Provisions
that may not be able to be implemented
but again I'll let the department speak
so I just want to bring representative
flury up to
speed okay so we're on
499 and Mr Ripple has begun to walk us
through the the new fiscal note the new
fiscal note is a separate document as
amended
April and we're on page two we're on
line two he was just talking about
breakfast after the bell and and I and I
already need to go back and correct
myself because breakfast after the Bell
actually is in section one not section
two section one is it still line 19 or
is it a different line now it's from
line one through line
good okay wait a second um go ahead
question the the um the the first the
first box that says positions what what
section in the bill is that there is no
section those are the positions that Doe
estimates would be necessary to
implement the bill but the bill doesn't
actually authorize them okay thank
you so the actual number of positions as
I understand it representative Buco and
I'm I'm checking with Mr Ripple while I
say this is that that's kind of the
maximum number of positions that would
be authorized if the bill was fully
implemented in accordance with the
Senate language if for any reason any of
these sections are not implemented then
that position count would be reduced to
some number that we don't now
understand yes thank you is that right
that's my understanding but I'll let doe
correct me if I'm wrong okay go ahead
follow up what what are the number of
positions if it's fully implemented that
would be the three new positions uh
program specialist for labor grade
25 again they're not established in the
bill itself they're what the department
says they would need and they're that's
referenced in the paragraph above the
table in the fiscal note oh okay thank
you I thought I thought it was in the
bill somewhere no okay so thank you for
pointing out that paragraph because
that's a good paragraph to
reference all right so you were talking
breakfast after the Bell yes section one
line one through 18 on page one yes and
then going back to the appropriation
table the next item breakfast program in
statistics for breakfast lunch uh that
one beginning on line
19 okay page
one uh question Jr or representative H
thank you um so back to the table on
page whatever we're up to um if the
breakfast after the Bell is currently
funded at a dollar but the cost was 3.7
million right is that going to be
changed to being 3.7 million because I
believe that's where the contingency
language would kick in the appropriation
would be insufficient and so the
department would not need to implement
it thank
you and same thing for the breakfast
program and the statistics you can see
again there's a dollar general fund
appropriation and an open warrant for
federal funds and the contingency
language would apply in this case as
well and and the basic explanation of
why the cost is in
terminable I'll I'll have to let the
department speak to that
okay so the next section in the table is
a little bit different because this is
the one doe piece that does contain a
general fund appropriation uh this is
the reduced price lunch program and this
found on page two of the bill it's the
and this contains an open warrant for
the general funds needed to implement
the program and as you can see from the
table doe estimates that at just shy of
year okay so moving on to the next item
online applications and uh the community
eligibility provision for participating
on page two uh the online applications
are from lines 21 through
29 and the community eligibility
provision I'm sorry 20 lines 21 through
32 and the community eligibility
provision is from line 33 through
five and that Community eligibility
provision does have a pretty big
estimated cost of about 7.6 million per
year again this is one of those sections
with a dollar general fund appropriation
and an open warrant for federal funds
with the contingency language if the
okay this this table that you just
highlighted I think I think we're down
to just summarizing with the state share
total of 12 million 121 okay so um is
there something in the writeup that
describes how much of it is is kind of
like doe money versus DHHS money this is
all these are all doe programs the HHS
money is covered in the second table of
the fiscal node this well this was the
second this was the third table we just
talked about so the second table is on
page one isn't it well which table you
so the table with the grade out section
in fy2 the longer one yeah that's the
doe piece got it and then on the final
page of the fiscal note there's a
okay uh represent hle thank you um I'm
not sure if this question is for you for
our chairman of Finance overall or for
Mr Ripple so is it possible if we do
another one of these fiscal notes that
we identify the tables relative so we
can sure that great follow up and then
what happens in the event where we fund
these different programs at $1 and count
on federal money to come in we so we've
established something but have right but
we don't have the funds available has
the doe given us any insight on what
happens to that program is it installed
postponed what do we know I don't know I
think doe would be able to speak to that
you are there any other questions are
are you do you need to do something
similar I'm sorry representative
Wier so there's also going to be a huge
cost for every local school district
it's indeterminant according to this
there's an indeterminable cost for local
school districts my understanding is
that that's mainly due to administrative
startup um but once again I would defer
to the department for a more in-depth
explanation there might be a school
district that doesn't do any breakfast
now and now we're telling them they must
do it that puts a whole new staff there
early and you know is that going to be
paid for by local taxpayers it's going
to be paid for through this bill which
is indeterminate which
could be three or four times the 12
million which I'm reluctant to to pay
for anything with that's so
indeterminate that who knows what it
would be especially when you go to the
summer uh feeding program there there's
a lot of loose ends in this as I see it
thank
you so so doe will come up next and
we'll plow into those details so so M Mr
Ripple on on the last page the DHHS
table M do do you see any need to um to
walk us through that or is that pretty
self-explanatory I don't think so it's
pretty self-explanatory this is a
combination of the two programs
established by the bill uh
the online elderly application uh so
this one contains an open-ended
appropriation
um so as you can see HHS estimates the
state share at 1.2 million in the first
year and that would be covered by the
appropriation section I will just go
back to the doe table for a second and
take a look at the bottom line and
emphasize that the total cost is estim
if everything is implemented is
estimated at 12 million in fiscal 25 but
again the only piece that's actually
funded with a general fund
appropriation um is the reduced price
lunch component at just shy of a half a
million
um representative em yes Mr Ripple are
these additive or is is HHS contained
within the doe HHS is not contained
within the doe they're separate but if
you look at the first page of the fiscal
note that
1.6 million general fund cost in fiscal
25 that's the combination of the two
you okay you just said it so I'm going
to frustrate you by asking you to repeat
yourself I think the the two the two
tables that are on page one with lots of
these sorry the the table that we
include in every fiscal note shows the
revenue expenditure and appropri ration
impact there's no revenue from any of
these Provisions uh but there would be
an estimated $1.6 million general fund
expenditure in 25 and that's the
combination of the doe and HHS
pieces um I say indeterminable federal
funds because again it comes down to
whether federal funds can actually be
used for the various new programs that
are established within
doe um and going down to the
appropriation
box there's a general fund appropriation
equal to what 1.6
million all right do do you think that
concludes your review of the fiscal note
I do okay are there any okay so we're
going to first make sure we all
understand the fiscal note before we
start going onto the next level are
there any questions for Mr Ripple
regarding the fiscal
note
represent thank you chairman thank you
for taking the questions um would it be
fair to say that while fiscal fiscal
note reflects your best efforts to
anticipate there are still a lot of
indeterminable and unknown items
there I think that's true there are
quite a few unknowns thank
you representative
hle thank you Mr chair so um again I'm
not sure who the question is for since
this is my just address it to the chair
then first first term on finance right
we're we're funding a program that
potentially is $12 million and with a
fiscal note that's 1.6 million that
would be actually allocated toward
that and then how do how do the local
townships and schools and the state doe
and anybody else impacted by this
program know what to do what what's the
guidance to them at the state level if
we haven't funded the
program I I think that's going to be a
great question and I think we're going
to wait for doee and have you ask it
again sure okay right now we're just
trying to make sure we understand the
the money piece of this and and I'm I'm
still frankly a little bit confused I'm
going to have to sit down later and just
go over it and try to figure out what
was just said but uh all this education
stuff I'm not smart
enough so thank thank you Mr chairman so
I'm glad you said that because there was
Mr Ripple said that that the total the
doe box there was
12,188 right
and and then it was going to subtract
that 499,000 out of the reduced Launch
Box I I think it was the other way
around of of that 121 the only part of
it that is for certain at this point is
the the 500,000 the 499 and
change is that right yes that's correct
okay I had it backwards yeah well I got
it right I still don't understand it but
thank you uh are any other questions
from the staff or excuse me from the
committee I just want to confirm go
ahead I just want to confirm these are
all incremental
correct all right uh not seeing any
other questions do our doe
and and I'll I'll start with a question
is is is is what you're going to tell us
is it um does does your
commissioner support this bill or are
you just here to provide information uh
good afternoon Melissa white division
director for learner support um the
department doesn't uh is neutral on the
proposed legislation we're just here to
provide the facts on what the
implementation would be and what we'd
actually be able to do um based on the
language that's proposed in this all
right so so now you're unhindered tell
us what you want us to know um so we
just want to be clear that the programs
where there's a dollar of General
funds
appropriated we would not be able to
implement those programs at all so
putting them into legislation we would
need some clarification on how we're
supposed to move forward why wouldn't we
just delete those delete the lines so
that those dollar indeterminant wouldn't
is there a reason why they're still in
there do you understand there's a reason
they're still in there sure I'm not sure
as to why that is still in there but I
do want to be clear there all of the
federal funds that we have at our
disposal to utilize for any of our food
and nutrition programs are completely
being utilized and so uh a breakfast
after the Bell program that is a state
program we could not utilize our federal
funds to operate that because there are
no federal funds to operate that
particular program so I just want to be
clear that we would not be able to move
forward with that um with the other
um programs as far as the uh c as
well again we've given an estimate based
on if all of our schools that are
eligible participated and if they did
the cost to the state would be the 7.
six million but again there are no other
federal funds because the feds are
already paying for that other percentage
for those C programs so so as an
administrative note I I'm I'm I I open
this as the chairman it's a joint
session because we're into a policy area
I'm unfamiliar with I'm I'm going to
turn the gavl over to the chair of
division two and let him direct the
questions the handoff but the reduced
$499,450 system to identify those
students therefore it would be um much
easier for us to implement we wouldn't
need additional staff necessarily to
implement that piece of the proposed
legislation so just wanted to clarify
but for the other programs the breakfast
after the Bell the online application
program The Breakfast program statistics
for breakfast and lunch all of those
other pieces the C we would need those
three positions in order to be able to
implement those programs those are State
programs those are not federal programs
therefore we have to have state funded
positions in order to operate those
programs we couldn't use federal funds
for that so what we have here is a is
kind of a fruit
basket you know pick your which one you
want and we're either funding in or
we're not but this is all for summer
feeding program no I think this is for a
year round
the the DHHS portion with the
pebt that's kind of separate from what
we're looking at with the Shaded table
that just has the doe component to it so
that's what I'm focusing on so this is
year
round um this is school year is my
yikes no really
confused cuz I thought I thought well no
I I I as I read this bill it was a
summer feeding
program uh but now it's not
so any Clarity from anybody please so if
I could it's the the doe pieces for the
school year and the HHS piece is for a
continuation of those benefits during
the
summer ah okay
Clarity please continue I I'll try not
question thank you I wondered if you
could go back for just a minute and talk
about breakfast after the Bell don't we
all we we do serve breakfast in a number
of schools and are they reimbursed with
federal funds for those breakfasts that
are
served thank you for the question um
just for reference Kelly Rambo Bureau
administrator for wellness and nutrition
at the department um that is correct
they are reimbursed by the um the
federal government for that there's also
some State funds that are that are paid
in that um there are currently 29
schools that do not operate um breakfast
in the um in the bill it is referencing
breakfast after the Bell um so that's an
additional um means for students to
possibly get breakfast if they might
have been late school or um something
along those lines that they missed their
opportunity during when breakfast was
served so that's what the um that's what
that program is for um and so the bill
speaks to um the department reimbursing
for the equipment costs to start and
operate that um and the reason that um
we have included that in there is um for
the the fiscal note is so that the
committee is aware of how much that
could possibly cost um because currently
the department does not keep statistics
on who operates breakfast after the
so presently we do provide Lun breakfast
for for children in all but 29
schools we provide breakfast in
459 it's 29 that that do not partip
participate currently um in that program
correct okay and but we can't the
federal government won't allow us to
provide that me that lunch that
breakfast after school starts I mean is
that what you're saying is it just
because we call it this breakfast after
the Bell or if we called it something
different could it be reimbursed by the
federal government so just for
clarification those meals that are
served after the bill are reimbursed by
the federal government what is being
spoken about in this bill is to give
those locations that do not currently
have that program in place because
that's not a requirement um to give them
the the startup costs for the equipment
in order to be able to um reach students
that might not have been able to get
breakfast during the time that the um
School
had designated for that okay so could
could I ask keep going you're you're
you're doing very well okay so what we
see in the bill is really the
$3.7
million is for equipment that's correct
it's not for any sorts of meal for the
child it's not buying food it's for
equipment that's correct that's what is
being requested in the bill and for only
those 29
schools no so the um as previously
stated the the department does not have
statistics on who operates currently a
breakfast after the Bell program so in
order to be fair and Equitable we would
need to provide to all of the locations
that are current this opportunity to all
of those locations that are currently
serving breakfast um so that's where the
3.7 um had come from for the equipment
purchases
there could be some schools that are
currently participating and wouldn't
need those funds but we need to make
sure that we made the committee aware of
if they are not what the the possible
cost could
be could if we are requiring in
legislation for them to offer
this could I just ask one more question
have you done have you done some sort of
an estimate of what you think it would
cost a school that is not presently
doing breakfast what it would cost a
school to um have enough equipment to do
the
program so our estimate for just
equipment was about
$155,000 could be up to a $155,000
depending on holding temperature um all
of those sorts of things um one thing to
also consider and that we we did put in
um in the fiscal note was that startup
costs to a school are indeterminable
mostly because because we don't know if
they currently have staff to provide um
a breakfast program and what those other
costs would be to the local level so
that's not those aren't statistics that
we have at the department and that's why
um that was
indeterminable good thank you
representative wer thank you Mr
chairman I would like to know the total
amount that gets spent for the whole
nutrition program and how what
so for for reference for last year there
was around $50 million that was pushed
out in federal
funds from the
I'm trying to think of the best way to
to give you that particular number um
and I might need to um do a little bit
more um research on that if that's
possible the other portion of it um one
thing to consider is that every school
district it's a local level decision on
what they're charging for meal pricing
um so it just might take a little bit
more to to figure um that portion out
for you that piece of it I thought I had
seen it in the education budget and as I
recall there was a maintenance of effort
so this fixed amount of money that we've
been contributing for years stayed fixed
but the total cost kept going up and the
feds were covering it am I
correct so the amount that is in there
is what the state is covering for the
reduced price
breakfast um and that is the the portion
that I believe is in um the budget that
you're speaking about you know I'm I'm
interested in the whole the the total
cost of the nutrition
program that's funded by the feds and we
put in a certain amount and my
recollection is they pay most of it that
is correct they do pay most of it and I
will get you um all right right correct
thank
you representative
H thank
you um I have questions so on the
breakfast after the Bell there's the 3.7
million startup
costs we don't anticipate that to go any
after the first year that is truly just
startup costs
correct thank you for the question um
is if every school
participated that's what it would be if
some schools don't participate that cost
could go to the next year and that's why
that is um those previous previous years
are are indeterminable um we would need
to work on a procedure processes on how
to um to reimburse those funds so um
that's also why we would need some
additional Staffing to to do that as
well too followup so so in the fiscal
note that I see the first year right it
doesn't discuss anything about beyond
the startup costs the actual cost for
the meals and anything else is that
above and beyond on the 3.7 million so
if there's food right if the 3.7 million
is the food out is the infrastructure
costs is there not also a cost for the
meals
themselves and that would be at the
local level that cost would be um so the
the bill speaks to the department just
um being responsible for the equipment
reimbursement so that's the number that
we have given in the fiscal note one
last question oh go for it so do we have
any any information on all of the
breakfast programs relative to food
usage versus spoilage
right that is not data that we currently
collect that would be at the local level
is there any way you can request that I
mean if we're if we're spending whatever
$10 million I'm pulling a number out of
the air for breakfasts
and half of it's going in the trash we
should know about that it becomes a real
number I'm not sure if we could measure
that I I just wasn't sure whether it
might be possible to know the number of
meals that aren't necess or number of
breakfasts that aren't actually
delivered they're they're made they're
heated they're stored they're waiting
for someone to pick them up and then
right they're they're thrown away
directly without going through the
students's hands I don't know I'm I'm
asking just for some level of usage I
think that might depend to at the local
level because I I'm just connecting it
to my my students experience and so we
have to sign up you know ahead of time
but we're not charged until they
actually partake in that breakfast so I
mean there's the sign up but they don't
actually incur the cost of the meal
until it's delivered so I'm not
sure how we would collect that but I can
I mean we could always talk to other
states and see if there's anything that
they do that we could look at to try to
measure that was M thank you I guess
thank both chairs um I appreciate and
understand why you need to make this
offer to all the schools you know in
terms of your estimates but at some
point you're going to find some schools
already have the equipment and some
schools are simply not going to
participate in the program for whatever
reason um when do you think or can you
get a more accurate fiscal note with
regards to who actually will need this
money in order to build out a kitchen
program thank you for the question um I
think that we can put out a a
questionnaire on on that um and then the
fiscal note would all the response is
back um you know who would participate
who wouldn't participate who would need
um the equipment who doesn't already
have a breakfast after the Bell program
follow up just you know adding wouldn't
that provide a more accurate fiscal note
than this is assuming everybody
participates and everybody needs
equipment um I'm just looking to try to
get a more accurate note for for that
particular part of the program
that's something that we can um that we
can put out and in request um I think
the the purpose of this is just to to
make sure that um we make the committee
aware of what it could POS possibly cost
um and we know that the numbers are High
um but we just want to make sure that
all of those that are entitled are are
in um able to get those funds if they're
available representive Edwards
uh thank you Mr chair I I want to change
subjects a little bit uh get getting
around the issue of the 29 schools uh on
page one lines 20 through
23 am am I correct to read that to to to
to to such that we we're changing from
which participates to shall participate
does that turn in is that effectively a
mandate to those 20 29 schools that for
whatever reason have chosen not to
participate that they shall be compelled
correct okay thank thank you thank you
Mr chair representative Heath thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question
currently most schools take the lunch
program and breakfast
program um I don't know breakfast after
the Bell what would that look like in
practice what would kids be doing what
would adults be
doing thank you for the question so
there are a number of ways that um the
the program could operate um and that
would be a local level decision on how
what works best for them um it could
range from students being able to come
down to the cafeteria after the bell and
and get their um what's called unitized
meal and bring it back to their
classroom um there could be grab Ando in
the hallway that would require some um
Refrigeration in the hallway because
that is outside of the the cafeteria um
so those are just two examples on how
that might possibly work um they could
get Innovative and have a cart that
might go out go around to the classrooms
um the other things to take into
consideration is you know you know
they're not disrupting the classroom
setting that's already going on um so
again that's a local level um decision
on how that would how that would work
custodial staff do you have do you have
the custodial staff to um you know
maintain that um as
well follow up so
um the $7 million that you're discussing
is the worst possible case scenario that
it could be but it could
be2 200,000
or a smaller amount because most schools
those 29 schools that currently do not
offer a program through the federal
system do they currently offer some kind
of a feeding program to their
students the C program is the um
component that is the seven the 7even
million okay um so that program is a is
a bit different than um the breakfast
after the Bell okay trying to find that
in the oh my
goodness but the breakfast after the
Bell program is the one
that we had put in the 3.7 for the
startup and then indeterminable right
thank you um but in terms of the 29
schools that that now would be required
to offer some kind of a breakfast or a
lunch program do you know if they're
currently offering a program there are
some that are and there are some some
that not but that aren't excuse me um
but as stated in the bill they would be
required to if they were
10% um they wouldn't be required to if
they were 10% for your reduced or less
so if they have 10% of children who are
free reduced free or reduced or less
they are not required to that that is
what the bill States so followup so most
schools offer a breakfast program and a
lunch program for which there
significant reimbursement by the federal
government correct um and um during the
summer there um there's a different
element to this but in past years it
seems that we've always run a summer
feeding program through the school
districts I and maybe it's just because
that was many years ago and I'm not
understanding what happens now did did
that
stop no um that program is a completely
different program from the school year
program there are different requirements
um for that program in order to be
eligible to serve meals at no cost to
the student so that um is a completely
different program uh than than um
what's for the Department of Education
um what is in um our bill follow what
yeah do you still offer Comm food
commodities to school districts is that
something that's still is available that
is correct that's operated through um
the department of administrative
services not our department and the
summer feeding program that's operated
through the department and that's for
like Title One programs during the
summer where they run a a a structured
program that's correct it could be a
structured program um there could be a
um what's called an open site so any fun
in the sun something like that um any
any child who is between the ages of
0 to 18 can come and get a a meal at no
charge so that's fully fully enforced
yeah that's correct okay yes that's com
that's um different uh than than what's
being spoken about here and and if I I'm
just trying to understand the different
elements we I think we all are so the
the program that we're talking about
would be like a a card that a family
would get that would offer them that
they could use
T so um I believe that that what you're
referencing is
SBT which is the chart on the back of
the page that DHHS will and that's okay
will speak about um what I believe
you're asking for for breakfast after
the Bell um if I can can kind of
summarize and and gather what you're
saying is that um you know yes we do
have a good number of locations that are
currently offered refering a breakfast
program this money that is um listed
from the Department um would just be for
even those schools that are currently
operating a breakfast program if they
wanted to partake in a program breakfast
after the Bell um that would be that's
what this money is earmarked for would
be um those costs for the equipment for
that particular program I I know it it's
I know it's a
lot I'm just not understanding why more
equipment would be needed for breakfast
after the Bell so if they're operating
in the hallway and they don't have
equipment to operate in the hallway that
would be those sorts of additional
things and and the department does not
have the data on um what equipment is
currently in a kitchen that they might
be able to take and transport into a
hallway so that's the that's what the
need for um additional equipment could
be and you're absolutely correct it
could be $200,000 because that might be
all of the schools that want to
participate in that um but we need to
make sure that the if every school
wanted to participate that we account
for um for those dollars so just one
more question okay um so if I'm a
teacher and I noticed that I have
um two or three children come who come
in barely on time and and they come
struggling in and I notice that they're
looking like they're starving and um I
know that they need something would
would they be eligible for the breakfast
after the belt I could say to them why
don't you get down and see Mrs so and so
and chill she'll set you up and you'll
be all set you'll feel better after you
come back that's the exact intent of of
the program yeah thank you very much r s
wner I think you
were one more question about breakfast
after the belt so the reimbursement for
this equipment you're making it your
fiscal note makes it available to any
school in the state but what about
section D here it says reimbursement for
breakfast after the bill described in
this paragraph shall be available to
school districts in which 40% or more of
the students are eligible for free and
reduced doesn't that in itself limit the
pool of schools so it wouldn't be 100%
of the schools it would be something
less and I don't know how many meet that
criteria that that is correct that was
in um the amendment so yes it it is the
40% excuse me it is the the 40% higher
for your reduced that would be eligible
for that um that amount of money and how
many schools in the state fall in that
category I will have to get that number
for you okay thank you so the section B
above is the part that
says the department of edge shall
reimburse school districts for the
initial cost for equipment necessary to
implement this alternative breakfast
delivery down below reimbursements for
after the Bell program described shall
be available to school districts in
which 40% or more of the students so
maybe there just needs to be some
clarification in the legislature that it
would only be for those school districts
that are 40%
more free and reduced because the way
that it it's written right now and I
think the way that we did our fiscal
note was so that we could Implement B
but then D would be um the component for
the reduced price meals so that those
meals would be then covered partly by
program but maybe the clarification
legislation needs to to spell that out a
little bit more clearly so that we would
know it would only be available to those
schools 40% free and
more
yes thank you Mr chairman um talking
about the various uh thresholds in the
bill the 10% that triggers the Mandate
and the 40% that we were just talking
about would it be fair to say that your
current fiscal note estimates expenses
based on the current list of schools
that meets those thresholds but since
those thresholds may change in the
future and the statutory language
Remains the Same there could be schools
that may be mandated in the future that
are not today that may be eligible for
that that may not be eligible or the
other way around so isn't there more
long-term uncertainty around the course
based on those possible fluctuations
um correct there could be different
fluctuations or changes in the future um
and the free and re I'll just say two
things one part is the free and reduced
applications and so in order to
participate in these programs families
fill out the free and reduced
applications we then base their ability
to participate in the food and nutrition
programs on if they're eligible with
through that but then there's also the
component that looks at our poverty
levels in the State um according to the
latest US Census Bureau data poverty in
the state has gone down to about 20%
compared to the previous year and so it
could go down the cost could go down
they could go up they could go down but
what we're seeing in that Trend it's
possible that it would go down thank you
that's why I use the word uncertainty
not one way or the
other I have a question uh in the prior
discussion you said that program is not
part of these programs how many other
programs are there just you don't need
to describe them just say there's two
or to that way thank you for the
question other programs this is a
yearound program um so the office of
nutrition programs and services at the
department
operates six and a half let's say um
programs and um so they range from what
we're speaking about now which is
encumbering of the the breakfast and
lunch program um we also operate the
child um and adult care program for food
we operate seamless summer we operate um
summer food service program um fresh
program and a special milk program
that's the half um and the form table
program on the way and we do have um a
farm to table Grant as well um so that
is the um all of the the federal
programs that that we currently operate
in the um in the nutrition office then
if this if this bill doesn't see the
light of day all those programs that are
going on are
unaffected what this is really doing is
adding a layer in the summertime is my
understanding is that I'm going give
getting
warmer I think
that there are a lot of components put
into this piece of legislation there's a
lot of different aspects and so I think
it can be a bit
confusing yes because there's so many
different pieces that are put in so not
to to draw attention to away from what
we were talking about but if you go into
the second page when we're looking at
the
um lines 21 through 26 that's focusing
on you know this very small piece here
the department shall adopt rules
requiring schools to offer online and
physical free or reduced price School
meals
application the it's a very simple
sentence but this is implementation this
program has a wider
implication for the local level and at
the state level because currently you
know there are a few schools that have
an online application and then they're
required also to provide a physical
paper but we also have many schools and
many leas that are not offering a
digital form to fill out so for them to
have to implement and be required to
provide that online form is something
that we have put the cost at being
indeterminable because because it
requires them to purchase a system and
offer that application they can't just
you know throw any application or any
income verification form in there it has
to be specific some schools can already
afford to do that some cannot so I just
want to be clear about that that there
are a lot of pieces within this
legislation that we just want to be
clear like I know it was difficult for
Mr ruple to kind of go through this
earlier and just kind of say well
there's this piece of it that costs this
much this piece is indeterminable that
online applications piece indeterminable
one sentence but it could have some
implications at the local level that we
just have to be upfront about and we're
not saying it's good or bad we're just
saying this is these are the facts it's
going to cost at the local level and we
can't tell you how much because it's
just going to be dependent on that
school and what they what they have to
implement that works with their system
let's dive into the weeds for a second
if I'm a school that says
leg legislation passes and it now says
you shall do this and I say I'm not
happened well that's a great question
but with $1 allocated probably not a
whole lot because there's no funds to
actually implement the program but I
mean it I think we do have to be careful
about what we're requiring I agree yes
thank thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question um I UND I want
to go back a little bit um to the
breakfast after the bell I I understand
the benefits of breakfast after the bell
and how it meets um students where
they're at which is sometimes coming in
at the last minute um after the seated
program um I know the school I'm
familiar with has a you know you can
enter the building at 8:45 and at 9:00
the second bell rings and you should be
in your classroom so they literally have
this tiny went out to eat the benefit of
breakfast after the Bell is they're not
as rushed and they can meet more
children but can you just clarify you
did use the word if if a school that
participates in school breakfast program
takes part in breakfast after the Bell
so this legislation will not mandate
their participation to change over to
breakfast after the bell and require new
equipment is that correct thank you for
the question as the
legislative as the bill reads that is
correct
it is not requiring them it is um
requiring the state to pay for that
startup equip startup equipment but if
they choose to operate breakfast after
the belt then they would be entitled to
that equipment if it was um if they are
40% or higher okay I just was cl wanted
to clarify that this is not mandating
that every school that offers breakfast
is going to require new equipment to
participate in a new program if they
already offer breakfast wh they're fine
as is if they want that's correct great
thank you representative
Edwards thank thank you I I I I think I
have a different set of questions but in
response to representative toki's
question I I I've now become confused by
the clarification because because
earlier we said that on page one lines
20 through
23 in fact change uh an a a law that
enables participation it changes it to a
shall participate and so therefore some
schools that have not chosen to
participate are going to be compelled if
this becomes law to participate in a way
they've chosen not to
yet two different programs be breakfast
after the bill separate going into
section two where there's line number 20
yeah that's requiring so that they shall
partic ipate in the National School
breakfast program un um unless they have
10% of
enrolled sorry unless the school
district implements its own breakfast
program or less than 10% of enrolled
pupils are eligible for free for reduced
price okay I think it's the sh they have
to I think I understand that so so so
now can I do my real questions um okay
so um it I'm I'm going to say what I
think I've heard in various DBS and
drabs as we've gone through and I'm
going to consolidate it and I want you
to tell me if I'm accurate or not and if
I'm not please please correct me of this
bill the only component of this bill
that builds on an existing program is
the reduced lunch Pro program the the
reduced price lunch component of the
program that this is an area that the
Department of Education can handle an
expansion of the program so that reduced
lunches become free to those that are
eligible uh and you don't need the
Department of Health and Human Services
to to support that component of the
overall bill is is that is that correct
if a a bill that just had that component
for that we're going to pay for the
lunch of our red news price students and
the state will cover that it costs
500,000 we estimate we could Implement
that starting school uh this school year
I mean I'm sorry fall of 2024 so we
could implement it hit the ground
running and complete it and have it
ready to go so so the policy decision
there is does the state want to take
reduced lunch prices and convert them so
that they become free to eligible
students is that is that really what the
policy issue is is that we're we're
confronting right now as long as we have
the funds to do so the 500,000 alloc no
I understand the funds but the policy is
that did I get the yes I mean we we we
know who those students are we know that
there's a need there there's no question
we could Implement that so so so final
go ahead okay so uh so so that's a very
specific policy question does the state
want to take reduced price lunches and
make them free for those ible children
and currently we do that for breakfast
that's that's a pause not a completion
okay so so that's the policy issue isn't
it normal that the that the the house
Committee of Education would make that
kind of a policy determination before it
comes to finance it sort of sort of
feels to me that we're being propelled
into making a policy decision here when
there's really money attached to it is
the only reason this policy questions
coming to us wouldn't this normally
wouldn't you normally be talking to uh
committee um yes or
no there are a number of bills that have
a dollar of General funds given or
appropriated for it that cannot be we
cannot do it without having appropriate
funding for it so I would say
that I'm not writing these policies I've
given my feedback on you know all the
components of this piece of legislation
it's I've provided that and then I'm
here to provide the information to to
this committee and I'll provide it to
whoever else um wants uh the information
will will'll always be there to provide
that
backup an observation Mr chair that that
it seems to me that we we're we've
skipped over the policy committee and
we've gone straight to the money and we
don't know what the policy committee
would want to do on on expanding this
program in this way to make free lunches
instead of reduced price lunges I don't
I don't think we know don't we don't
know okay and so then the rest of this
bill seems to have a lot of
implementation complications it's not
and it hasn't been obvious to us in the
last hour so it just seems like it may
we may want to schedule an additional
work session that I hadn't anticipated
because this is more complex than I
thought it would be represent tki I just
want to clarify we have yet to hear from
DHHS which is a whole other part of this
bill that I'd like to dig into and I
believe we're running out of time
so I mean we haven't even touched on
that other part of the bill would that
be the U the summer summer EBT and the
bill okay I thought adequacy was fun to
play
with Mr chair oh I'm sorry no worry
thank you I appreciate Mr chair thank
you um I just wanted
to make sure I understand that what when
we are talking about the reduced price
launch becoming uh free we are moving
from a graduated system where people who
are at a certain level get free and then
people get reduced and then people pay
for it we are moving to basically a zero
to full price system would that be
correct if that part of the bill is
implemented paid for by have different
funding source and So currently of
course of course we are paying with
State money because the feds only pay
for part but I'm talking from the point
of view of the people receiving the
benefit they would now have two Cho two
categories of them either people who get
free lunch or people who pay full price
whatever we charge at school level there
wouldn't be the intermediate reduced we
would still have that category just like
we do for breakfast right now the state
currently pays for the reduced price
students to have so we still need to
identify those students we still need to
um for all of our other purposes yes um
but yes students that previously would
just have paid a reduced amount which I
think is a 40 cents up to 40 cents we
would be covering that cost so from from
that point of view my question is
obviously from our side we got to keep
doing the same work but the perception
the you know reception from the
people who received the benefit side
would be that now there would be you
know zero or full price launch with
nothing in between correct and I also if
I could mention too that we have a
number of families that fluctuate back
and forth so one year they're free the
next year they're reduce and they go
back and and so I would say that this
would greatly benefit those families
that you know they're on that that that
cusp and we can provide that
okay thank you I'll turn the gavl back
over now for HHS portion all right uh
thank thank you Mr chair
um so DHHS how do you all want to
represent
present so so miss Fox are you are you
hiding from us or are you just going to
strategic second strike if Miss Ebert
says something
wrong oh okay all right so so miss Ebert
let me let me first just try to make
this simple for for for my head here uh
is is it the case that in this bill the
relevant portion of this bill from the
Department's perspective the Department
of Health and Human Services
perspective starts at page three on line
six and basically Al runs through the
Appropriations section um which may go
all the way down to page four uh line
19 is is is that that that's really
about the Department of Health and Human
Services is it not yes and just for the
record Karen heer director of the
division of economic stability for DHHS
so yes and and all of the discussion we
just had on the doe components of this
bill
does not imply any action by the
Department of Health and Human Services
this is almost as though it's a wholly
separable bill at that point is is is
that correct yeah the sections for the
Department of Health and Human Services
are not dependent on the doe portions of
this bill so it's separate okay so with
that clarification in mind just tell us
what you want to tell
us uh I'm here to certainly answer any
particular questions that you have um
you know with respect to the fiscal note
or the the language that's in the bill
um I will clarify that the language
that's in the bill um while the
department certainly supports the
concept of a summer EBT program for
those families who would qual those
children rather who would qualify for
that particular benefit it's designed to
complement the school um uh school year
programs
uh for uh meal programs that are offered
through the schools uh so this is a
benefit specifically to um continue um
supporting those particular children who
are eligible for the meals benefits
during the school year to be eligible
for benefit during the summer
months uh so what's what's important to
note however is that the summer EBT
program is still subject to the Federal
government's approval of our state plan
uh specifically the US Department of
Agriculture and the food and nutrition
services we have submitted a plan a
draft plan to uh the federal government
for summer EBT specifically to would be
initiated for the summer of
benefit uh however we have included in
that particular plan certain conditions
that need to be in place in order for us
to implement M this program that
includes funding that is part of the uh
part of this particular
bill so at this point what I think I
just heard you say is that for the
summer of 24 if we were to pass this
this portion of the bill the department
would have the ability to execute uh
because we are allowed to rely on our
own systems our own methods but that by
the time summer of 25 comes along we we
may have some new compliance
requirements that are not completely
clear to us we've submitted a a plan we
have not received feedback yet from um
the Department of Agriculture of the
federal department that they've approved
our
plan partially correct we have submitted
a plan specifically for the summer of 24
benefit we have not submitted a plan for
25 it is not due until
August uh so we'll be working on that
the fiscal note for fiscal year 25
includes the cost for standing up the
program starting in the summer of
24 but because there is a
requirement that for a summer of 25
benefit has to be dispersed 7 to 14 days
before the summer period so we basically
have to dis
the summer of 25 benefit in June of
25 still during the fiscal year of 25 so
the costs associated with this
particular fiscal note include costs
that would support standing up the
program and distributing a benefit for
summer of 24 but also Distributing a
benefit for the summer of
25 summer of 25 benefit is what the
state will be required to meet a number
of requirements from the federal
government to be able to implement that
program they're allowing a number of
flexibilities to States for a summer of
24 benefit because they know states are
having a bit of a tough time and trying
to meet all of the requirements set out
in the inm final rule for this
particular program so they're allowing
some flexibilities so that we can still
do a dispersement for children in the
representative wer and then
representative walner thank you Mr chair
where is it envisioned that this feeding
will take place in the
summertime for the summer of 24
benefit yes so it will take us uh
probably until uh October or November to
disperse the first iteration of a
benefit for the summer of 24 what we
depend upon is a data file from the New
Hampshire education department that
includes a list of all of the children
who are uh eligible and certified for
the national school lunch
program those are the folks who are are
eligible for the summer EBT program and
we don't get that file until October or
November so so I think the question was
more related to whether or not there's a
a central feeding location or Central
feeding location
and and I think this program is set up
to take existing EBT cards and make them
charge them so that they can be used by
the families during the summer but since
we can't disperse the money until
October it they are not really going to
get a summer 24 benefit they're going to
get a Halloween uh
treat correct and I apologize I
misunderstood your question well you
have followups well it seems like so if
it's an EBT wherever they buy the food
or whatever else they want to buy with
the EBT card not not necessarily food so
there's no uh eating at the school in
the summer time because it could be
closed for construction or cleaning
correct it's not the the physical uh Act
of eating it's receiving the benefit on
an EBT card electronic benefit transfer
card so that they can use that money uh
and for many folks um uh they would be
using the benefit in addition to SNAP
benefits that they may already have on
an EBT card so that they would buy uh
groceries using the EBT card during the
summer but I just to clarify if if I'm
if this passes and I'm going to the
local school during the summer to get my
lunch breakfast whatever I'm going to
get and then in October I'm going to get
an EBT card for the summer of 24 I get
double I'm double
dipping I I can't speak for the school
programs that they may offer during the
summer this is specifically a um uh a
separate program I I understand that
that's why I'm asking it's a separate
program but it could be the same
student yes okay thank you did you have
a question over here that's okay I was
go are there other questions from Miss
Hebert do do you have did this trigger
you want to want to add more what you've
already told us uh I will take any other
questions that there may be so
representative Heath and then oh I
skipped you representative walner uh
let's do representative walner first and
then representative he okay you got
you so I'm looking at the fiscal
node and um I see that
the biggest impact in the fiscal node is
the systems cost and I think when you
were here before at the public hearing I
think I I asked you about the systems
cost I mean that is a
onetime cost that this that will last
this program into the future that's
correct so we put that so even though
it's a big hit at the beginning it lasts
a long time correct okay and can you
remind me how much um each child will
receive on their EBT card
for the summer period it is a total of
$120 $120 for for the full for the full
month thank
you representative Heath thank you um my
just a quick question what is the source
of your data what where do you draw your
data to obtain the um free and reduced
lunch
count so uh initially we well two
sources we have based the number on uh
what's projected by the US Department of
Agriculture they did a projection for
each state but then we also took uh
combined that with information we had
from pandemic EBT so we had summer
pandemic EBT for the last three Summers
So based on the number of children who
or families who applied for that and who
were eligible under the school meals
program were able to refine that number
a bit more uh so that that's where that
comes
from um does that include medic
we have asked the uh yes it we we have
asked uh that as part of our plan
proposed plan to include those children
who are Medicaid eligible thank you very
much represent
Murray thank you and I think perhaps you
can help me clarify I've sort of walked
myself in a loop here when I was first
reading it and you talked about summer
2024 I thought it meant summer 2024 but
then you were talking about the money
not showing up until October my first
understanding is that they would receive
the money in 2024 and y'all would get
reimbursed but they're not it's actually
the the EBT card the individual who
won't see that boost until later in the
year as opposed to receiving it in the
summer and you receiving the
reimbursement later correct the state
doesn't front the funding it is a direct
benefit from the federal government so
what's happening is that because we are
having like all states having some
challenges in implementing a summer 24
program we can't put something in place
that actually delivers the benefit
during the summer months of 24 it's not
physically possible so the best that we
can do is get out a majority of that
benefit by October or November after we
have worked with the Department of
Education thank you for you're welcome
so just I got to stay clear on this so
so what I think I just heard the Nuance
is that the EBT cards once they're
active and capable
get uh loaded directly from the federal
government but it isn't until after
October or so for the Department to have
enabled those EBT cards somehow in order
for the money to hit the card and so
therefore the the kids the families
still won't get the $40 a month until
October at the at the best correct
there'll be actually two iterations just
to be perfectly clear yeah so for those
uh children who are we we know will be
eligible for the national school lunch
program we will receive that information
from the New Hampshire education
department here's a list of all the
children currently eligible we can issue
a benefit of those uh those families as
soon as we have that
information it may take 30 days you you
need to go back to months because I now
you've got me on Summer in October are
you adding another date in here for the
summer of 24 benefit that's the only
benefit I'm talking
about we will get uh the inform we will
get a list of the children who are
eligible from the Department of
Education we will get that list roughly
October it may take 30 days for us to
get the benefit out the door to those
folks but we also plan to open up an
application period for amilies who may
not be on that list but would still be
eligible uh so say they uh just moved
here from another state or they uh
didn't apply sooner for the school lunch
program but they've recently applied so
they didn't make the list so we have an
application period that we're going to
enable families to apply for the benefit
as
well that will take probably another
month to be able to
then keep that window open for f for
families to apply for the benefit and
distribute so I'm still trying to put
things on my mental calendar the the
application period to get the kids that
are aren't on the list opens what in
October you still have to do do some
system work and it'll be October or
November before they can begin the
application process yeah the application
process would probably open up sometime
in November okay represent
tki thank you um so we've dug in a
little bit to the summer EBT program can
we turn to the elderly simplified
application and what the department
would what requirements you would have
to implement that maybe you can first
explain what it is and then if there are
costs associated sure essentially the uh
thank you for the question essentially
the elderly simplified application
program is is an option for states to do
exactly that
simplify the application specifically
for uh the population of uh individuals
elderly or disabled individuals who
would qualify for that benefit uh
because they're not earning there's no
earned income so we have about 7,000
individuals who would qualify for this
but it basically would uh uh one of the
the greatest benefits to that program is
that it would uh allow for a longer
duration of uh the benefits so that they
don't have to apply every year uh the
duration could be as long as three years
so it would save individuals from having
to come up with verification
documentation and having to do that
every single year uh there may be
challenges for people to be able to get
that information so it's meant to
simplify the process for them it would
also simplify the process for staff and
reduce the workload on them um the only
expense to this is a one-time system
cost which is included in that number
it's a
$75,000 sorry uh uh half of that uh for
um General funds to be able to implement
the system changes needed for that are
you staying around
$37,000 yes no um no
75,000 is the total
cost for system changes for the elderly
simplified application period so it's
okay because I'm I'm looking at the
table the table says systems costs is
752 th000 that includes summer EBT and
that and that and that number is the
aggregate of the sumary EBT and the
elderly simplified application correct
so you're saying that if we only did the
elderly streamlining that would be 10%
of that number or about
no the the federal government would
reimburse as 50 it's 50%
of of so the systems cost for that piece
would be about
you okay
$37,000 of State money if that's all we
did it would make it easier for our
elderly to instead of reapplying every
year they would apply once and it would
be good for three years correct is that
that's a fair summary yes okay now
there's a reason they we've had them
reapplying every year is that is that
because we're concerned about fraud if
somebody dies or what why why what was
the initial rationale on a
year uh that's the that's the program
that is the way it has been uh as long
as I am aware do we need to worry about
fraud if somebody dies and somebody use
to draw the benefit I don't think so I
mean I think that we're always Mindful
and it doesn't change um the the
duration of the period so I I mean we
receive information automatically uh
with respect to individuals who have
passed so I'm not not sure that that
would be a conern so there's no
additional fraud risk by extending the
time frame no okay are there other
questions
okay uh we we are we're scheduled to end
at 2:30 so we're pretty much there I
think we've broken down this bill into
many of its component parts and uh and I
I I'd almost suggest um U representative
emmerich that division 3 really focus on
um that that uh that third page starting
on line six to for the rest of the
relevant stuff and then division two can
arm wrestle the all the other programs
and and talk to the education committee
to determine if they have a policy
perspect I I I don't know how we get
there from here this is a lot of policy
I know read how what what what what's
your idea on how how we divide this and
we get it to the finance committee that
makes the most
sense I'll take the education piece and
you take the uh HHS piece okay I happen
to have this on the calendar for the
209th uh which is the the next work
session for for this bill for for and I
think I think that was meant to be a
joint so so you would have to figure out
what your next meeting would be that
29th I I don't know what's in the
calendar you may not even have to
recalendar it I don't know we could just
sir okay so on the 29th I think I booked
us for 1:00 for another joint or that
positive yeah so that that's that's when
we were going to do some more joint work
you you could maybe we could meet in
separate rooms at the same time I don't
know if that addresses the calendar I
didn't hear what representative wer said
did you said you have had something he
morning so division two could meet at 10
o'clock in
209 okay that's our
plan well now we changed because
formalar okay so um so I think we have a
general plan um you got a calendaring
thing for next week uh we're going to
keep the calendar for division three to
focus on our share of the bill at 1:00
on the
29th um and then I guess we'll huddle to
see what kind of we overall proposal we
have on 499 to the full
committee okay okay um is there anyone
in the audience that has wanted to speak
that hasn't had an opportunity to
speak no you're not being compelled to
speak but you are being invited should
good afternoon I'm Laura milikin from
New Hampshire hunger Solutions um just a
couple of things I mean I think I think
it's come across that the pieces that
are funded in the bill are are the uh on
the doe side the reduced priced meal
pick the state would pick up the cost
for the reduced price kids to eat free
meal
and on the DHHS side uh it would fund
the startup costs for sumary EBT which
is a new federal program so new federal
dollars would be coming into the state
and it would be the systems costs that
are required um to access those federal
dollars um and then uh I think that um
uh Karen uh explained the the elderly
simplified application project the other
pieces in the bill the $1 pieces were
intended if there were federal dollars
or available as I understand it um of
course I did not amend the bill but um
but that that was my understanding um
and uh from talking to the sponsors that
that that was the the intention um that
only if federal dollars additional
federal dollars were available not not
federal dollars that the doe currently
has um but if for example for breakfast
after the Bell if there were additional
arpa dollars one thing I'll say about
breakfast after the Bell which again is
not actually funded in this bill but it
is a program that's intended to uh
reduce stigma and increase participation
and breakfast right now only about 48%
of the kids who participate in free and
reduced meals partic uh sorry who
participate in free and reduced lunch
participate in breakfast and that's
because schools generally offer
Breakfast early in the morning so
sometimes there are time issues that
kids can't get there but often it's
because the only kids who eat breakfast
before the Bell early in the morning are
the poor kids and as soon as kids
realize that that's true they'd rather
go hungry than participate in breakfast
but there but breakfast after the Bell
is an evidencebased approach you make
breakfast a part of the school day
Everybody Eats breakfast nobody knew
knows who's paying and who's not just
like lunch so that's uh and so the
intention in the bill was to create
incentives for schools to do the
breakfast provision
differently um not schools don't have to
do it but if they want to do it there
available so I think you brought Tom
celic with you today
uh well welcome back to the house house
uh The Honorable bro uh Brody uh Des Des
thank you thank you um do you have
anything I have nothing to add now but
I'm I'm here to Avail myself of any
questions um if it's needed but thank
you all right are there any questions
yes uh representative Who's the who
Who's the champion on the community
eligibility provision the C program
who who do I look at on that one I I
can't figure out who to who to talk so
I'm not sure I I uh so the community
eligibility provision is a provision
that's available for schools with high
poverty kids high percentages of kids
who are living in poverty to offer
Universal meals at the school level for
for all kids for free and
the the federal government reimburses at
a higher rate um based on that those
poverty percentages but right now of the
90 schools in New Hampshire who could
participate in the community eligibility
provision only about two are um and
that's because it is um until you
implement the program it's hard to
realize the economies of scale it's it's
hard to know uh how much the exposure is
so the idea is for the state to help
incentivize schools to be able to use
those federal dollars to feed the most
kids in in in a way that produces the
least stigma so the that program does
not apply to the elderly or the dis
disabled does not does not it does not
that's a program for schools um and
again the amendment changed the
percentage of schools uh that that could
be funded
but there's $1 to fund that program it
is not a funded it is not funded in this
bill
representative thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for being here just a
clarification question you said that
breakfast participation is lower because
lower income kids are the only ones
eating breakfast later when breakfast
you know later breakfast is not offered
could you help me understand why because
I genuinely you know I'm not sure why
that happens and I'm sure you do
know yeah yeah I mean my understanding
is that
um if breakfast is only offered in the
cafeteria um and only before the
Bell um and buses don't usually get kids
there that early unless they're the the
identified as the free kids then they're
identified as the free kids I know of a
school that has um free and reduced they
call it uh
early free and reduced breakfast I mean
you know you don't have to be
um you don't have to be very old to
understand um
that if it's called free and reduced
breakfast then everybody know and you go
everybody knows you're a free and
reduced kid I'll I'll also add um
representative that when it comes to
busing schedules there can be a very
tight window for students to be able to
participate in breakfast I mean if your
bus for example like I can think of our
local school district buses get there
between for high school about 7:00 to
7:10 and classes start promptly at 7:25
so to expect a student to go to their
locker drop off some of their stuff or
even take their stuff with them through
the lunch line to get their food I mean
at a certain point often times students
are ending up eating in the classroom
and that's because teachers are either
permitting it or teachers who really
don't like that happening in their
classroom it becomes more um you know it
becomes difficult for a student to be
able to eat eat all their food uh that
they've been able to acquire so than a
flag just a clarification
question obviously a school calling it
that way is a something that that school
really needs to change I you know I
thought they were supposed to not uh in
any way distinguish between how kids are
treated right based on their ability to
pay and all that so that would be a
clear corrective action that the school
should take so we leave that out of the
discussion of these bills but if that
breakfast program is open to
anyone are we saying that because free
and kids eligible for free and reduce
are more likely to make the effort to be
there that's what identifies them as I
said I'm genuinely trying to understand
because it would seem to me that if the
breakfast program is open to everyone
well whoever shows up for breakfast
shows up for breakfast how would you
know whether I you know I just like
eating the school breakfast or I need to
eat it because I qualify for free and
reduce
again I'm trying to understand where the
stigma comes from because obviously
that's something that needs to be
addressed I just need to understand why
this is the best way to address that
stigma rather than other potential
representative it's past 2:30 and I'd
like to wind this down understood I'm
good I think we're getting into uh sort
of an American cultural issue that the
kids that went to Junior High probably
understand and we can talk about it
offline um but the stigma is real I'm
sure um the the the what I picked up in
this is that there is um uh an
implication a secondary effect that a
bunch of bus schedules are going to get
changed if we pass the this
bill no no may I may I clarify something
I I don't think that is the implication
at all good good that's why I'm asking
the question the problem is like we were
discussing the window and I mentioned
earlier the window of time that the
children can enter the building and then
have to be SE sitting at their desk for
the start of the day the school I'm
familiar with that I worked at is a
15minute window however that doesn't
mean those children get off the bus at
the beginning of that 15minute window
they may get off the bus five minutes
before they need to be sitting at their
desk they have to throw their coat off
race up to the cafeteria grab their food
and they're now eating in a very
unhealthy way so the breakfast after the
Bell allows more
participation and a better program for
the child not to feel rushed and have to
Wolf down the food if if if I may Mr
chairman the goal is to make it so the
school date doesn't have to be extended
because that's a cost of the property
taxpayers by integrating it into the day
thank you both everything that she
mentioned would appreciate it are there
any other questions because I'd like to
close
this okay not seeing any questions we
are going to close the work session on
SP 499 thank
you uh with that I'm going to go ahead
and open because it was to start at 2:30
the work session on SB 406 that's a
division 3 only so uh I I'm going to
immediately call us into recess for five
minutes so that people can take a bio
break and we can reorganize who's in the
minutes
e
okay so it it being um past our recess
time and we've gotten the education
people out of the sandbox with us uh
we're going to open division 3 work
session we have two bills we want to go
over uh SB 406 SB 311 uh by a show of
hands who's here to talk about SB
406 okay show of hands who's here to
talk about SP
311 so let's do let's do four 6 first so
um I want to invite Miss Fox up and Mr
White if you want to join or you're
welcome to or however you care to
now of does does everyone have a copy of
SB 406 on the
committee I I have 406 because we heard
all right thank
you go ahead introduce yourself sure so
good afternoon I am ktia Fox I'm the
director of the division for Behavioral
Health and I'm here on S SP 406 in
support of the bill and the funding for
our shelter programs in the state I do
want to um provide a little bit of
information that came up this morning
during the hearing um as I said then and
want to reiterate there are
950 beds that are funded by the state
throughout the state and the funding is
flows through 13
organizations and they are um located in
all regions of the state we as a result
of the hb2 funding that we received we
had um the funding available for two
years um of the additional $4 million
what we decided to do was that we were
poised to procure for shelter Services
as you know we want to go out and um uh
out to bid um frequently enough so that
we can um make sure we're getting the
best price and also having the
opportunity to see how the shelters are
doing we were not in a position to be
able to do that in time for a July 1st
start so we took the funding that was
available effective July 1st um and we
distributed it among those existing
shelters that we were in contract with
we then went out to bid and um on March
27th we received governor and councel
approval for the new contracts
and what I wanted to distribute to you
is the easiest way to tell you where
those shelters who the shelters are and
where they're situated is to provide to
you a copy of the governor and Council
letter which has the name of the
contractors who the where which area of
the state they serve and how much
funding they received for that um period
which is April 1st 2024 through June
30th
2025 I thought that would be the best
way instead of recreating a um table um
that you would be able to see how those
uh funds are distributed and which
programs are serving which areas of the
state that that that sounds good Mr
Ripple would would you would you hand
those
out while that's being done can I ask a
question so uh most of the discussion we
had was about increasing the
$20 uh day rate that we pay to the
existing shelters to a $27 rate for
existing shelters are we saying that
this two and a half million is going to
all go to new contracts and none of it's
going to go to the existing contracts
after that discussion oh that that's a
great question thank you it is our
intent because of um the way that the
bill is written is that we would
distribute it to the contractors who
just entered into contract with us so
the ones that will you'll see um in this
table are the ones that would receive
the additional funding and we would do
it based on the same formula that we use
to allocate the funds that were provided
in
followup well I see I see 13 contracts
on
here and
um uh which ones are the new ones that
are going into effect in April these all
went into effect April 1st um and all of
them so this was a brand new procurement
brand new contracts um you can see in
the in the letter that it's um the
option to renew for five years these are
the ones that um should this uh Senate
bill pass um that we would um distribute
the funds
to so um weren't these facilities
providing similar Services before this
contract and was State partially funding
them at the at the $8 a day rate so I
believe that um as a result of the
procurement there were a couple of
changes so there were some um programs
that decided not to apply and there were
new ones that were funded but
essentially these are the core shelter
state
question I just have a quick question we
heard briefly this morning about the
need for um specific Youth
Services um for homeless and I know very
recently in Nashville we had a couple of
unrelated to the state funed programs
but we lost um some local service
for youth homeless and it also made me
think of the increased need for services
for lgbtq youth or adults um do you have
any information on um specifically to
those two communities if they would be
able to benefit from this so um these
programs do not address that population
we do have um recently um wayo um in
Manchester has has a young adult shelter
and they receive funding through gopher
um and um that is a program that was
stood up I believe during the pandemic
and they um they built that shelter they
renovated that shelter and so we have
that and then there are other programs
that are funded uh for children's
residential treatment services through
our children's Behavioral Health um in
in the mental health budget and the
division budget so those are separate
yeah so I'm I'm looking at the bill that
was submitted to us uh and it looks like
it's had some amendments um how is it
you read it so that only these 13 would
be eligible for a share of the 2.5
thank you um that is a great question
that is how we would operationalize the
bill as it currently stands um as you
can imagine to repure or to have this
funding go to different programs and go
through that whole process wouldn't
achieve the goal of providing that
immediate funding um that the shelters
themselves indicated that they
need okay so what I think I heard heard
you just say is that you all are making
um a a prioritize you're prioritizing it
so that you can get the money out
quicker and more efficiently and because
these contracts only went into effect
one April the implication is that it's
easier to amend those contracts than the
ones that have been in place
longer so yes I I think you said it more
eloquently than I did but yes it would
be the most efficient and effective way
to distribute the funds and these
programs were just selected through a
competitive bid process and so um to
take the two and a half and do a whole
new reprocurement or procurement just
for those funds would be um lengthy okay
so the the reason that we don't want to
go back further than one April is now
again I'm just trying to understand the
situation is is that uh those were
awarded on
non-competitive basis uh Soul Source
kinds of things these were competitively
awarded so even though the work may be
similar in terms of every contract is
going to need an amendment to change the
rate right yes whether the contract was
signed one April or July 1 the the the
amendment to the contract would
essentially be the same and a sheet of
paper that says this amends the rate to
this new rate right so um there are no
contracts that um were prior to they all
expired on March 30th and so as of April
1st these are the shelter contracts that
are um state funded throughout the state
that's good data and like I said the um
the programs are essentially the same
there are just a couple changes again a
couple of programs that chose not to um
submit a bid and a couple of programs
that were funded that were
new thank you so um so that makes sense
why those would be the ones you'd go
amend because you actually have active
contracts that are amendable so that
that makes sense um the um on on this
chart or table that's on um that she
sent to the executive counsel I don't
see uh bed counts or bed capacity per
facility and I'm understanding from your
testimony that these 13 add up to a
number less than
950 they do um so they you're correct
and I can get those numbers I didn't
have time to um get that um in between
what does it feel like to you of the 950
is this about 400 of them oh this is all
950 there are 950 beds represented here
one thing that I should know is that the
New Hampshire Coalition against Domestic
and Sexual Violence is a Statewide
program they put submited bids for their
10 centers which are located within each
of the counties so they act so when you
see 13 agencies um that particular one
represents 10 actual um shelter
programs but but they do equal
950 so I'm not very good at math I I
took $2.5 million divided by 950 and
then assumed a 300 day uh year instead
what what do you think this really
calculates down to then with the 950 2
and half million do you assume 365
operating days a year in your
metric yes I believe that's how we
calculated it it's $7 above and beyond
um so you um I'm not the uh the one who
did the calculation but I do know that
it was a $7 increase per bed so somebody
who's good at
it's yeah
okay and so representative Stringham
well I looked at eight and a half
million divided by 950 beds so that's a
little less than 9,000 a year divided by
365 days was $24 51 cents a day so so
the current are getting 24 what 60 51 51
if I could just interject um this is a
15-month contract since it started April
1st and so that total number of
8.5 um gets us uh 15
sheet
okay that sounds
right uh represent
wer so prior to April 1st these beds
were getting reimbursed from the state
at
$8 a night and we go up two and a half
times that and we still have a demand
for
more um thank you I want to make sure
I'm clear on this and it does get
confusing the $8 per night per person
was um what was in place before the
legislature passed the new monies um so
as of July 1st it went to
$20 um and so once we had the new budget
we were able to put those rates
immediately into those existing
contracts we went out to um procure um
but we so it's been $20 since July
1st not so not yet a year two and a half
times increase and now they're coming
back for more it seems like they really
far I don't know how to respond to that
other than the the cost as you heard
testimony this morning and what we've
calculated is
$47 um per person per night um and we
with this bill it would increase it to
$27 so there's still a gap um The Gap is
being closed and I think again the
testimony that was provided this morning
um was that these um funds are needed
for staff and I know that Rockingham
County said
couple hundred thousand to one of the
ones that's in our County as
well that would be the other fun so
right um do you have followup
sir
okay uh
what what what I understand then is that
these 950 beds we don't expect by adding
the extra $7 or so per day we're not
expecting any new beds to open
but what we're looking to do is to avoid
losing beds because some of the entities
may have to exit the business absolutely
how what what is what what's our risk
how how big a margin is a risk are we
talking about uh of the 13 I you I don't
want you to say specifically which ones
are vulnerable but do you have a good
sense of which one of these are
vulnerable to potential um um bankruptcy
or whatever the term would be in this
world I don't I don't have that
information I think um what we want to
do and this is included in the bill is
to have that so-called fiscal Integrity
provision as part of the contracts the
amended contracts so that we would have
the insight and the financials to be
able to understand on a monthly basis
how those agencies are doing so we could
monitor
um any such circumstance as a
catastrophe so did you just suggest
you'd like us to amend this bill so we
put the financial Integrity language
into the law it I I believe what is in
here is um would um address that I don't
see the phrase Financial Integrity
anywhere right we call it fiscal
Integrity in our contract language but
essentially that's how we would
operationalize um the fact that um
I'm just what what words say that I'm
just missing it and I'm I'm happy to
amend this to to to to get what you
think makes good managerial sense I just
want to give you the
tools I'm not I'm not seeing it in the
language
though hi Mr
White good afternoon members of the
committee Nathan white CFO DHHS um the
the appropriation language that you see
in this bill mirrors the appropriation
language that was provided in hp2 this
past session the the fiscal Integrity
language that Kat is referring to it's
part of um some of the internal
operational uh system of controls that
our our centralized contracts unit uh
incorporates we actually have a risk
assessment process um so in the case as
many of you probably recall we talked a
lot about subrecipients and contractors
during this past budget session um when
we do have subrecipients we assess those
uh those organizations for a certain
level of risk and that's required by un
by federal uniform guidance and so when
we see more of a a higher risk scenario
whether it be Financial or programmatic
we go ahead and incorporate some of the
standardized language that we've
developed to protect the department in
in relation to that risk so I don't
necessarily go ahead that all sounds
good but Miss Fox I think just said that
we don't have visibility of these 13
which ones may be vulnerable how how
would we assess uh relative risk between
these 13 and and therefore assert the
fiscal Integrity language
yeah I'm I I'm not trying to be
argumented I'm just trying to help you
understand I want to understand so we
can help you get the language the way
you need it to make this money as as
valuable as possible well I I go ahead
so I'm sorry as you said um this bill
has been amended several different times
so the version that I have in front of
me which is 411 2024 which is amendment
65 and so it's the one that's um amended
by the Senate yeah it does address this
by indicating that the department shall
require recipients of this funding to
submit Financial projections covering
the term of the contract as well as
ongoing financial statements
demonstrating organizational Financial
sustainability so that that's lines 8
through 10 yes okay all
right um okay I want to I want to shift
gears on you a little bit um I earlier I
think we heard that we had um people
showing up at the uh shelters with no
identification and that they're they're
receiving uh these scarce valuable
resources even though they're not
presenting with any identification is
that did I hear that
right I do not um get into the details
of how the programs run but I believe
that's what we all heard this morning um
about the housing first model okay so so
this confuses me about the utility of
the language that's on line seven where
it says that we we shall prioritize
veterans to the greatest extent
practical and and so that language is
meaningless if we have people who are
able to show up and claim a resource
that might have gone to a veteran
that that's my observation tell me if
I'm
wrong I don't think that I could tell
you you're wrong I think that um the
idea is that um housing first model is
really about harm uh reduction and about
making sure people don't die so this
language is is useless then is what I'm
what I'm picking up is it because the
housing
first policy of the federal government
overrides six and seven to where line
six and seven so that six and seven are
just throw away words that mean
nothing in
practice I think that um I would want to
bring that back and see how we would
operationalize that with the uh shelter
programs I think you heard from families
in transition which is still in the room
um about the um priority populations
that they have which include veterans
yeah so so if I could just wave a wand
uh I would say I want to prioritize the
elderly that are starting to show up I'd
like to prioritize the veterans who are
showing up and I would like to under or
deprioritize anyone without any
identification can we do that legally
not to say that as a group we agree to
that we're not there but I just want to
know if that would be a legal thing to
do I I would not know know how to answer
that I would have to um defer to
somebody who knows case law and um an
attorney likely yeah can can you all
take that question back and research
that because I'd like to take six and
seven and I'd like to put some punch in
that so that we're we're really
prioritizing veterans and the elderly
who are showing up um and and and and
taking away the resources that are being
claimed by people who are showing up
without any
identification um and I do think that if
you have the opportunity to talk to the
shelter programs about what the
day-to-day is like and who shows up and
how um access is gained to a program um
in determining um whether they're
holding beds for a particular population
or whether it's first come first Ser so
so I talked for 30 seconds with Maria do
I need to talk longer
we we we can maybe talk about that so
okay um so that's that's the whole issue
on undocumented in this issue around
eligibility of low barrier housing um I
I want to I want to understand that to
see if we have any influence at the
state level um because we're crowding
out the
elderly and the other question I have
for you is if we do have an elderly
person that's making decent money but
still can't afford an apartment in
today's crazy rent environment are they
able to make a contribution or a
donation to help cover some of the costs
of the shelter or are we sort of by
practice or by law prohibited from even
inviting a
donation I don't believe there's any
prohibition against uh such okay but
it's probably not being done because
it's not expected that these folks would
contribute to their own housing
I'll defer to the programs to be able to
respond to that I think that you'll find
um there are instances where individuals
have availed themselves of those
services and gone on to be able to
achieve economic stability who have then
come back and contributed sure I'm
familiar with like the Liberty house
model yes so I I like a lot of the
Liberty ass model but um and
then I really would like to use this as
a as an opportunity for the state to do
something like a house resolution saying
that we need our federal delegation to
take a look at the housing first policy
if if if we were to make if we were to
recommend changes to the housing first
policy so that we could have a more
sustainable healthier environment and
these shelters do you have an idea of
two or three things that we might want
to suggest gets relooked in the housing
first
policy I would have to take that back
I'm not sure could could you come back
with that you got that Mr White or or Mr
Ripple I don't know if you're writing
this down or Mr representative Stringham
you got these okay somebody's got it do
what okay I'll come over okay so we
notice that the
hospital is concerned if we lose
capacity that they're going to get
further backlog than they already
are um so we don't want that to happen
we definitely want to keep you guys in
business I think um all right so that's
really all my questions representative
torki did you want to
speak well I just didn't know if um we
were going to dig a Little Deeper I just
had a response or a reflection when you
were talking about people who showed up
without ID the language of the bill
actually talks
about legally present in the United
States those are two different
things I'm
online8 you're T you know prioritize
veterans and shall not knowingly provide
services to any person not legally
present in the US to me that's two
different things people who are
houseless are have a higher propensity
to not have identification it doesn't
mean that they're here illegally so I
guess that's just something that we as a
group can work out and I didn't know if
the um the um women who testified
earlier about from their facility could
maybe
discuss that if that's a concern of
yours no I think it's a great point and
the reason I already got myself to being
comfortable talking about the lack of ID
is because I understand that the the the
the that every day 138 people line up
and they have you know X number of
minutes a limited time frame to just
check everyone in and and many of them
are showing up without ID they don't
have a a window of time set up to to
formally check eligibility against
things like the Medicaid New Heights
program or they they they don't have on
the ground the ability to check whether
or not somebody's in the country legally
or not that's my understanding I'm
seeing a head nod uh but but we can
continue that conversation which is just
simply to explain I you know I I agree
with you in general but from a practical
point of view I I I don't know that we
have a different proxy other than to say
do you have identification I that's fine
I guess I'm just concerned about um you
know putting people without
identification at the bottom of the list
be since people who are houseless are
often the most likely to not have
identification even though they are
legal citizens of the United States
that's it I want to make sure that we
can clarify that when we come to our
final product no I I agree and but just
keep in mind that because we're we're
filling our full capacity we're we had
testimony that we are uh excluding some
of the elderly and possibly some
additional veterans who might be
eligible for that resource but are not
because the room at the end is already
taken so if we're really going to try
say as a matter of policy we want to
prioritize veterans and I'd add the
elderly uh to that uh policy preference
then and we have a scarce finite
resource how do you shift around the
priorities the bill already anticipates
that veterans are supposed to be getting
the greatest extent practical of
priority but but I think we heard that
that mean those are meaningless words
and I agree with you when you said that
that line is somewhat meaningless and
I'm curious if the original Bill had
that or if that was something the Senate
added on to try to um set safy
someone thank you very much okay so
representative H said that that got
added on so uh representative
wer we heard testimony from some of the
people that ran these shelters that they
helped people get IDs and I mean I
remember being involved with a veterans
program years ago where they had
somebody there from the registry of
motor vehicles and they they could look
back if you'd ever had a driver's
license and lost it or expired they may
find find an old one and oh yeah that
looks like you you may be able to
reproduce it so you know that's that's
also part of the services and if
somebody comes in and says I lost my
wallet all my ID and everything they may
be able to reproduce I think that was
one of the services we heard was
provided so you've got to try to do some
of that work too as well thank
you and I and I would just put out there
also that having a valid identification
card in our Society the way it's
constructed has enormous utility for all
ranges of things and so if we're if we
are experiencing a a class of folks who
are having trouble having an
identification card it's kind of in our
interests as a state and as a society to
facilitate them getting
one I am 100% in agreement with you
adjourned oh representative Stringer go
ahead
uh couple questions looking looking at
your chart um contract number 12 is the
Salvation Army in West nyak New York is
that correct do we send uh homeless
people out of state as part of the
contract now no it's not that's where um
the Contracting and their Administration
is um they serve uh bamp and marac
counties thank you and um uh if if we
did the math uh or each each one of
these contracts have the same day bed
rate is that the way the contracts are
written or is it just a fixed total
that's based on a lot of different
things the contracts are actually
written where it's a cost reimbursement
basis um and so um it's just easier to
convey it and say $20 $27 because when
you look at those reimbursements and you
average them out they are they come
agency follow up yeah a cost based
reimbursement when the cost is 46 and
how we how we going to make this work
when we're paying half that much or is
our expectation that they're getting
private donations of a certain amount
thank
you so um our CFO next to me is we're
talking about the contract we'll take a
look at it and get back to you on that
are are there further questions for the
Department uh ladies do you want another
chance another bite at the Apple to talk
to us you talked to us this morning
you've heard us yaking a bunch do you do
you have something else you'd like to
say I I don't have any questions do we
have any questions from for the families
in transition organization
anyone representative stream yeah I just
wanted a clarification thank you m thank
you both um um when you said you had uh
2.7 million in I think you said in
donations this morning those are from
charitable would be in addition to what
you get under your state
contract yes and it actually supports
the entire organization so um I believe
this morning we handed out a a flyer
that had yes so that just covers um the
shelters that we run we also run housing
and a food pantry as well as a substance
use treatment program so that 2.7
million
supports all of our programming where
there's a gap okay so so while you're
sitting there I I asked you offline and
and if you could confirm I heard you
correctly um due to the way people line
up and check in for the for your shelter
um I understand it that you have really
no practical way in which you could make
a a proactive positive check on
immigration status that is correct all
right thank you I will also add um one
of the things in regards to veteran
status or actually anyone um not every
shelter does this but because we run a
day program if our participants stay
during the day they secure their bed for
that night so they still have to go
outside to do check-in but they're
secured their bed already for the for
the upcoming night so when such as a
veteran comes in they work with our case
managers we know that that person is a
veteran or a youth or somebody else who
can be better served somewhere else
that's where that information is then
given to another organization so
veterans would be referred to Easter
Seals uh Liberty house another
organization and that is through the
case management piece it wouldn't be
through the piece of an ID um it
definitely has to be through the
services piece so once the person is
actually inside that's the
that is the time when we're AB we're
able to provide the services that are
critical do you have an ID do you have
any income do you have your birth
certificate all those things to actually
get somebody to housing so even checking
IDs at the
door wouldn't help you get to what you
need to get to to get all the services
it just would get you in the door if
that's the way it would be
written okay hypothetical scenario
somebody shows up up they they receive a
bed they have no identification mhm but
they tell you and they're telling you
the truth that they used to have a
driver's license but they've lost it yep
how long would it take you working with
that client to uh obtain a replacement
driver's license depending on where they
got their driver's license new um I
don't think it takes very long it's
really just sitting down with them
making sure that they're giving us the
right information their birth date
everything that they need um this is
part of the services that we actually
will pay for for them to get their
driver's license or ID non-d driver's ID
um their birth certificate social
security card anything like that so so
something they can get it 90% of the
time within a week oh it's probably
longer than that that I could ask my
case managers it's going to take a
little while to get all that three
weeks does anyone know how long it takes
to get I'm going to say as someone who
recently moved to New Hampshire trying
to get my New Hampshire driver's license
it can take up to 45 days
yeah go ahead I was just going to
comment though the piece that you just
said which was birth certificate the
birth certificate is that vital missing
piece that many of these people probably
don't have particularly if they were
born out of state and that's the
challenge is figuring out how to access
and have the funds to be able to access
it um correct we pay for that yeah so
that's the part that could take much
more
yes the other difficulty is often in
order to get one of these vital
documents you often need to already
possess at least one of the others so
when you have someone who has none of
these documents it becomes very
difficult to start that process because
if you need your birth certificate you
have to need a form of ID already all
right and and earlier I asked if you
could come up with two or three bullet
statements was that you I asked about
two or three bullet statements on on on
issues within the housing First Federal
policy that seem to cause us the most
aggravation yeah I think um housing so
we get a lot of money from HUD right so
um we we have to be a housing first
organization um if the state grant and
aid do provides a different model that
would be a contract that we would follow
through um the state but our all of our
housing
has to be housing first the reason I
wanted the two or three bullets is
because I'm toying with the idea of of
doing a
resolution from the general court to the
federal delegation to say please look at
these issues they're getting in the way
yeah and I think for Sheltering I mean
it we're like all the shelters who
talked this morning are all low barrier
shelters and it is really about harm
reduction um and it is once somebody
gets into a shelter it's then the time
to talk with them about where do you go
from here cuz this is not where you're
going to live for the rest of your life
um and
so I don't know how that would affect
the Sheltering business per se because
it is just a place for someone to stay
for a period of time but from a housing
perspective we're required to be housing
first and our money from HUD requires
that so and and you gave us a length of
state number didn't you an average
length of stay what what what it what
was it was on our sheet of paper so
our family shelter um most of our
families are staying between six and 9
months because there's no place for them
to move to and this money goes to those
family shelters it does and then our
adult shelter is 38 days on average all
right the most stay between I I I I
appreciate everything you all have done
to make us Smarter on this thank you so
much are there other questions
representative priest could you just
clarify that last statement about how
many days for adults
yes on average we have adults staying at
our adult shelter for about 38 days the
majority of them though are staying
between 1 and 14 days though we
certainly have people who stay many
months um sometimes even longer um but
the average is 38 days okay if we Ser
about 850 men and women uh each year
through our adult
shelter any further questions from the
committee any final comments you want to
share that we've not asked
about no we want to representative PR go
ahead uh again I'm I apologize for not
being here for the hearing I had a
municipal to EXA out so um how many
families do you see on an average we
serve 11 families uh in our building on
Lake a um but we have a weight list of
62 families currently right now okay um
but and our families typically stay
between six and nine months um because
there's very little place for them to go
okay thank you anything else I've got
that yeah all right so with that uh I
think we can conclude SB
406 and open SB 311 thank you so much
thank you all right and you have my card
I'd like to still stay in touch I I
think no you gave me your
right
yeah in 15
minutes 10 minutes okay I actually think
we could be done in 10
minutes um so who who here from the
go go ahead I I think we know who you
are you've introduced yourself good
afternoon one too many times huh um so
we um just following up on the public
hearing there's a there's a couple of
members who were not here at the public
hearing and I just want to provide some
context and overview uh the state
acquired Hamstead Hospital officially on
June 8th of
2022 um prior to the acquisition of
Hamstead Hospital there were concerns
raised from the town relative to the
loss of property taxes that the town
would experience um at that point in
time the parties that were involved had
agreed to um make a payment in Li of
taxes pilot um to use an acronym not
that we want to use acronyms make this
less accessible um and over the past uh
two years in state fiscal year um 23 and
24 the state made uh payments to the
town of approximately
80,000 each year slightly less um during
the budget process uh during the Senate
phase after the house phase there was no
Committee of conference this past budget
um the senate had uh verbally agreed to
add uh an appropriation to the budget uh
to make payment to the town of Hamstead
uh that that did not make it officially
into the budget um so the the sponsor
Senator Bell um as she spoke ear uh at
at the prior public hearing her intent
was to include this uh for State fiscal
year uh this payment um the reason the
payment is so precise in in the in the
appropriation is it basically represents
the exact property tax loss of the town
for the three Parcels of land that
Encompass the H the Hamstead acquisition
um one one key piece of information just
for everyone's awareness there is a
state law that prohibits uh localities
from taxing the state um there's an
exemption there and uh for context as
well the department has submitted
relative to those payments uh separate
requests to the governor and executive
Council to authorize those payments
which they have done so for the past two
State fiscal years um the and I'll pause
there for questions so so wouldn't the
appropriate way to do this in the future
is the in the governor's budget phase
the Hamstead hospital and eventually the
youth development center that is going
to be co-located there they're going
they're going to they should be
proposing Monies to that for them to
transfer to the town and it should just
be part of the budget cycle should it
not that that could certainly be one way
to do it from a transparency perspective
let's do that so that the cost of
Hamstead hospital is a fully loaded cost
and we're not always doing a side deal
let's just put it into the budget since
we we're committed to doing it is there
is there a better way to do it a more
efficient way a more transparent way uh
establishing class line is certainly a
transparent way to achieve that so yes
we're you're we're agreeing that going
through the budget is the best way to do
it okay a representative H I have two
questions sorry for missing missing the
public hearing um one was
this the taxes were calculated on the
current value of the property including
the buildings but if we do Renovations
or build out for the replacement for the
cunu center obviously the valuation goes
up are we anticipating paying for the
new taxes for that new building as well
um Can can I answer that I I would hope
that the state has staked out the
position that we would not that we're
replacing the property taxes from the
prior owner of the land and our
improvements to the land because we're
exempt from a property tax perspective
should not be factored into a a new
higher rate that we should
grandfather the the the value and maybe
have an inflation adjustment at some
point but but I I would not want to U
I'm with you I'm just checking because
do do you have any reasons inequity here
for all the other owned government owned
properties with all in all the other
towns that we suddenly start yes yes sir
so so Mr White since you know more of
the details of the agreements has has
this topic come up about future
improvements to the property value and
what it may do to our payments in Le of
taxes I think there have certainly been
discussions relative to that um I I
think the key question for today though
is is is the the the policy question at
hand relative to the the immediate
payment um there there there is no
written mou between the state and the
town of Hamstead um but there have
certainly been many verbal discussions
relative to that
right okay okay representative B thank
you Mr
chair is am I correct understanding that
the state does not make any such
payments in any other situations such as
this the department does not the state
does there there are other scenarios
where um the state do do make
payments can you name some of those um
the I know that the department of
administrative Services makes a payment
to the town of conquer uh to address the
um the loss of revenue from parking due
to the general General legisl the
general court being in session um I I
would I would have to I mean I think
we'd have to request from the Department
administrative Services a more
comprehensive listing as I'm not fully
aware of what other agencies have in
their budgets okay I can name another
Kevin you want to I did uh request that
commissioner Arling house provide that
information he said other than the
payment to the city of conquete he
wasn't aware of any and that payment is
175,000 annually okay that was Myan as
well speaking to him the last week as
well so um with that in mind going back
to the original discussions about Hamad
hospital was this third year part of
those original discussions I I first of
all may start go backwards my
understanding was that there was some
discussion of the first two years
property taxes being included in the
original deal is that accurate um I I I
think this past year was certainly on
the table G given the fact that um we we
did make a request during the budget to
incorporate that um into into this Bania
okay so so the answer is yes so the
question is was is the third year which
would be the next one that starts coming
up the one we're talking about here
right was that included in those
discussions not not included in those
discussions was was that agreed to when
the property was purchased with
hamston is what you're implying right
well that's who it was purchased from
yes yes yes yes yes yes what yes that
that was part of the discussions given
the long-term loss and the impact of the
town no not part of the discussion it's
part of the agreement well there is no
written
agreement so what in your mind what were
the discussions forever
impu I wasn't privy to those discussions
I was not in in my current role so I
can't speak to the exact nature of
them okay but you are speaking to the
third year anyway yes I'm speaking to
the third year that was requested during
the during the budget process and and at
the and our
expectation based on those discussions
what that would be included in the
budget during the budget process but not
necessarily during the purchase
process during the purchase process and
and just to be clear because this did
come up and I'm I'm going to answer your
question but I also just want to address
a a misstatement that or potentially
misunderstanding from the last go around
um the agreement was between the state
and Hamstead Outlook LLC which is a
private organization the town was not
part of that agreement so there is no
legal obligation it however there was of
course the um the negotiations between
the state and the town and the many
ongoing discussions uh that have taken
place since that point in time based on
the loss of property tax revenue and the
impact to the town and services so I
understand a lot of that and just was
number of years part of those initial
discussions I I don't think there's been
any 5 7 12 15 Nature um to those
discussions okay thank
you represent wer I'd like to cite
another example that seems to get
overlooked in all these discussions of
this of the state paying for um loss of
of property
tax some years ago we were talking about
state of Massachusetts Connecticut River
was was damned to protect Massachusetts
from flooding and it also involved
several flood zones most of them being
in handful of of U towns in New
Hampshire that because of this agreement
agreed to close their flood planes to
development and every year the state was
paying property tax reimbursement for
the loss of value the towns would
otherwise have and the reason it came up
some years ago was Massachusetts was
also supposed to pay for this loss of
development and it took about 10 years
in a lawsuit to finally collect that
money but that was another example of
paying for um property tax loss to those
towns and I I don't know why the
administ of services and all these other
people when this question is asked did
we ever pay anybody else for Lo loss of
property taxes yes and that's probably
half a dozen towns so that exists and
it's I don't know why it's never
mentioned but I brought it up thank
you I know representative Stringham you
had a question I well I think I think um
um Mr White answered answered the issue
which was I was just going to point out
we had separate te testimony that that
the the state bought the property from
Hamstead uh Outlook LLC I think it was
called and there was there was no
agreement at the time of the purchase to
cover lost um Lost Property Tax it's
like anytime any property converts from
a non let's say it's purchased by a
nonprofit institution that doesn't pay
profit not not uh required to pay
property tax it's something that the
towns have to deal with with and um um
uh you know to the town's credit they
brought the issue up and something was
worked out so that they had an unu had
an unusual payment uh at least by our
state standards in the 80,000 and the
issue is um uh whether whether this
after the deal um Arrangement should
continue for additional years at least
this budget cycle and then perhaps in
perpetuity
is there anyone you'd want to hear on
from on the 29th would you like any
representatives from the town of
Hamstead to to be invited for example to
help us understand from their
perspective what they think the
agreement was and when it was made it
clearly it was all verbal and handshake
there's no written document but would
would that would that help you
understand um yeah I'd be happy to talk
to anybody it doesn't have to be
committee but yeah so
he's representative Guthrie you're
you're you're Hamstead selectman is that
why you're here yeah Hamstead yes
Hamstead select
oh okay no I just thought you were here
because you
know have a
seat oh no pleas please please have a
seat because we have an interested party
right now let's party party so so um
what do you think representative Guthrie
was the understanding of the town of
Hamstead as the state moved in and
purchased uh the hospital and uh and
took Hamstead off the property roles
well it on case of the Hamstead side was
a lot of
lobbying and maybe a little bit of arm
twisting and hugging with the Health and
Human Services Commission and that's the
type of thing it was and it went to uh
presented by the health and human
services to the executive commission
with the support of the governor and it
was
really to to get us over the bump if you
will we would all of a sudden here goes
Revenue that we don't have and that was
pretty much what it was and uh my
feeling is that uh our request at this
time uh shouldn't be connected to
anything that's going on in the future I
I course I can't speak to it but when
they build the facility as we see it uh
the impact that that has on our
community may you know that's that's
that's a whole new ball game and I I'd
be uh wouldn't be fair if you didn't say
if I'm sitting here as a as a uh
selectman that I wouldn't be advocating
for some assistance somehow or other uh
whether it be money or other otherwise
because
uh this does impact uh on our we're
already uh uh just last night we have
voted to for new uh firemen if we can
find them on our in our department we
just got a brand new chief on the police
and we've put added police officers so
uh I I it wouldn't be fair that that was
caused by Hamstead hospital but the fact
is uh you know we're going to have to
provide service
so I can't speak uh for the future and I
would not want to be uh tied down to say
that we wouldn't be in some vehicle here
before you sometime in the future asking
what can you do for me so I it only fair
to say that but I don't think they're
connected I think this is just the fight
that we're fighting today if it is a a
dispute represent tki thank you um just
to
clarify what the thought process is Mr
White can you remind us
um House Bill one that this division
reviewed was there a line item for this
property tax reimbursement and question
two was it the Senate that then took
that line item out in other words did
your department come to us prepared
to have the state pay this
payment uh I don't think I can answer
the answer I wasn't involved in that our
Senator Senator blae Dell was the one
that was running with the ball was not
involved I think the question was
White I I would have to go back and and
just look at the exact history of the
agency um requests that were made at
each phase and I I can provide that
history okay I just don't want to speak
out of turn but that's okay yeah I just
was thinking forward that if the
department put it in the budget and it
was removed for whatever reason and you
know their plan was that's part of the
operating costs for the property moving
forward and I think it would instead of
talking about this as a oneoff it may
help us understand what the Department's
view is of the property as a whole that
that is part of the expense to running
the program that's
adjourned all right I hope so any other
questions okay so I I think ready to
close uh SP
311 and as we close SP 311 I'll just ask
Mr Ripple if he's got any thoughts on
what we need to do to get ready for the
next session on thank you for coming
thank you Mr chair thank you uh for for
Monday we're meeting at Monday at 1 I
can't think of anything in particular
unless there's anyone you want me to
invite anyone you'd like to hear from on
this or the other bill can we ask the
Hamstead CFO to drop in is it they have
a CFO I or something like that sure I
can ask okay okay that'd be great do do
you have anyone you want to talk to I
was just wondering if you could remind
us what's scheduled for Monday at 1
o'clock so we can my head we're doing
this one and we're doing all of them oh
I think yeah yeah we just needed to
intake these and then on Monday my plan
was to um make a determination what we
want to do with them and and and make a
recommendation to the full finance
committee so essentially I I was hoping
to be able to exec all or some of them
on
Monday are there are there any other
questions okay so with that um this work